we talked yesterday about uh the
difference between the cost of goods
index and the cost of living index and
how the numbers have been manipulated so
to hear that the old way to calculate
inflation would be over 14
is pretty powerful when you combine that
with all of this negative yielding debt
what is the event that ends that entire
part of the financial industry and how
long do we have until we get that to
essentially blow up right and i don't
think anyone's cheering for it to happen
but the writing's on the wall so how
long do we have and then what is that
catalyst that ultimately blows it up do
you think risk happens fast okay you
never think it's gonna happen and then
all of a sudden it's all over you but
to be clear i i agree with you i do not
want this to happen and i don't want it
to happen fast i believe in the long run
it will eventually happen
but what happens what are the events
well let's be honest the united states
currency as global reserve currency
today will be the last fiat currency to
fail
okay that's
just how it works you can look in the
credit default swap market you
understand that the us treasury market's
the biggest the most liquid it's got the
most staying power
but what happens in credit markets is
this thing called contagion
and what contagion essentially is is
what you've seen happen with evergrand
in china and it
percolating higher in the credit
spectrum to where it's actually impacted
the credit default swap rate or the
expected default probability of the
country of china okay now china's credit
rating
is single a but it's
the credit default swap market is
telling china you know what you're
trading much closer to a triple b you
better get your acting gear kid because
you know what a triple b credit is right
on the cusp of being high yield or junk
and using the pejorative junk i was a
junk bond trader for many years
all it takes is a few downgrades into
the junk spectrum and there's a cascade
of selling and this cascade of selling
then causes contagion into other markets
so china being the second largest
economy in the world if all of a sudden
the debt markets say you know what china
you're sort of ugly you're you're a
you're a junk bond borrower equivalent
they'll be contagion to other economies
pop that it's you know even though you
know china would be a g8 country
absolutely it'd be a g2 country but
it'll it'll fall down the credit quality
spectrum something i call the risk
ladder and it'll impact countries like
you know uh
argentina which is a g20 country but
it's defaulted four times in my life
already now i'm not predicting that i
want to see this contagion but that's
what happens in credit markets okay
one guy seeks protection by shorting
another market and that guy's who's
shorting that market causes a cascade of
selling in that market and it's just
like we saw in the great financial
crisis okay it starts to accelerate the
second derivative
is the most important
okay the acceleration of the change will
cause
am i saying this a u.s treasury bond
auction to fail
highly unlikely but what about a canada
bond auction failing
ooh and canada is a g7 okay so look i
don't want this to happen and this is
why we need this parallel network we
need to develop the bitcoin safety net
we will have a bitcoin store value
savings account and we will have a fiat
currency checking account but don't save
your money in a fiat currency checking
account
so when you think about all these
pension funds and financial institutions
that are holding so many bonds what
happens when they all drop it is that
the acceleration you're talking about do
they start to say hey look there's you
know 14 percent uh inflation based on
the old calculation there's five percent
on the new calculation uh i can't
possibly continue to hold these
treasuries because i'm actually losing
purchasing power and not protecting my
assets i have a fiduciary uh kind of uh
responsibility to protect these assets
so i've got to get into some other asset
does that just accelerate everything
once one starts to do it they all start
to do it
yes and no okay these are investment
mandates that have been written
over time there's investment policy
committees these things don't change on
a dying pump now maybe the smart people
are sitting there much like the houston
uh fire department or the guys in
chicago if you haven't heard of them the
uh the blue collar bitcoin team that is
a bunch of first responders in in
chicago who are very concerned that
their pension plan owns a certain number
of fixed income securities because it's
in their investment policy guideline i
mean if the pensioners rise up and say
what are you holding these things you're
guaranteed to lose money on a real basis
maybe it percolates to the investment
policy committee but remember these
investment policy committees are are
dominated by people who want to cover
their ass right they don't want to make
these decisions uh what happens though
is if one person a big fund let's say
cppib in canada or calpers in
uh in the united states says you know
what this 60 40 model is pooched uh i'm
gonna go 60 20 and then 20 in
alternative assets that do include a
certain amount of uh bitcoin that really
gets the ball rolling because it it
takes the uh pressure off of the theory
of agents they call it you know as long
as one of the big guys moves in that
direction then i can cover my own uh
investment policy decision
when you start to think about the
timeline for this to occur for them to
all start trying to move capital because
of this uh this mechanism is this a five
year or a 10 year or 15 year thing how
long do you think it takes
yeah it's it's a process so some will
move early and some will be the last and
uh as a canadian i can almost certainly
guarantee you that the canadian
knuckleheads will be uh one of the last
ones to move okay so that that pains me
because you know canada had we've sold
all our in our central bank we've sold
all our gold uh canada does not have the
safety net that the us does we're not as
big a
country obviously we don't have the
vertically integrated and horizontally
uh integrated economies that you guys do
uh listen it it happens because
uh out of necessity let's do some quick
math if calpers has a uh
eight percent
return
bogey um and it's a 60 40 uh it's a 60
40 uh mix and 40 is in bonds and those
bonds to be generous are earning on
average over their whole asset makes
let's say it's earning three percent
right so three percent times forty
percent that's one point two percent
they're getting in their whole portfolio
from bonds that means the sixty percent
that's in equities has to earn
the difference eight minus one point two
is six point eight percent so six point
eight percent divided by sixty percent
of the portfolio means equities have to
return 10
forever going forward in order for
calpers to make
their bogey
um i don't know
like you know yeah they're going to be
some good years but over time you don't
hit that 10 bogey especially when you're
at all-time highs in the s p which you
just pointed out so there's a lot of
stuff going on it's absolute certainty
the mathematics of it
almost certainly unattainable and if it
is attainable it's only because the fiat
currency is is uh pooping the bed so bad
that it appears that your uh equity
markets are actually going up when uh in
fact it's just the unit of account is
going down right